Another review role is that of the reader. Reviews should be systematic and
thorough. One way to deal with this need is to explicitly address each part of
the artifact being reviewed. For example, in the code review, each line should
be individually looked at. The reader is the person responsible for
enforcing this thoroughness by leading the participants through the artifact and
for each part paraphrasing what, what the artifact is expressing for
that part. The paraphrasing should be its, should be descriptive, and
not try to say why that particular part is there. Some organizations run their
reviews with the artifact's authors being the readers. Other organizations make
sure that someone else does the reading. I think in the case of the first type
of organization, the thought is that an author might buy us the discussion
by emphasizing certain things, the author felt as important, even at the expense
of perhaps hiding some details which need to be looked at more carefully.
In either case, the reader should use impersonal pronouns such as it,
referring to the artifact, rather than referring directly to the author with I,
or he, or she, or something like that. Personalizing a review by using I and,
and you, and, and so on, can raise the defensiveness level of
the participants thereby reducing the review's effectiveness.